avec axel ronde secrétaire général du
syndicat de police en-avant bonsoir
monsieur merci d'être avec nous sur rt
france également à vos côtés entonnant
peschard avocat vous avez été avocat de
la famille du jeune fofana qui est mort
à 22 ans le rappel après un contrôle de
police bonsoir merci beaucoup à tous les
deux d'être là pour débattre de cette
question des violences policières de
l'article 24 qui a été beaucoup contesté
hier dans les rues de france on va
parler tout d'abord de cette affaire est
clair quatre policiers qui risque la
mise en examen ce soir
axel ronde votre réaction écoutez on
s'attend effectivement qu'ils soient mis
en examen ce qu'on espère c'est qu'il
soit pas qui se ne sera pas déferré à à
l'issue de la présentation aux juges
parce qu'il ils sont quand même restés
faillite et qui s'était quand même des
fonctionnaires de police
donc il ya toutes les garanties
nécessaires pour qu'il se présente
devant la justice donc nous attendons
bien évidemment russie lankais taxquet
qu'elle d'ex qui déterminera vraiment ce
qui s'est passé c'est plutôt rare de
voir un procureur prendre la parole dans
ce genre d'affaires qui est allé assez
vite finalement antonin peschard un
candide ou oui mais je vous remercie
d'abord j'aimerais rebondir sur ce qu'a
dit monsieur ronde
si vous me le permettez c'est à cause de
ce corporatisme que le discours de la
police et n'est plus audible
c'est à dire que vous présumez que parce
que fonctionnaire ces personnes ne
mérite pas la détention provisoire
excusez moi mais disque aurait plus que
choquant dans ce genre de dossier un nom
policiers par en détention provisoire
sans qu'il y ait aucun débat sans qu'il
y ait deux possibilités la détention
provisoire monsieur et vous le savez
plus que quiconque
elle va se justifier par le fait
d'empêcher la concertation du discours
des policiers et dans les rares
situations dans lesquelles nous avons eu
des cas de violences policières
nous savons très bien qu'elles sont
couvertes par la rédaction des procès
verbaux qui sont rédigées ensuite au
commissariat et on en a un témoignage
vous pouvez faire l'amour mais on en a
en un témoignage d'un journaliste
monsieur qui s'est infiltrée dans les
locaux d'un service de police
20h10 panon nous fallait qu'ils les
dénoncer pour moi c'est juste vouloir
soucis et c'est ça qu'il faut dénoncer
monsieur c'est ça qu'il faut dénoncer
ces cas une souche pure dans la police
ou quand vous êtes jeunes vous rentrez
dans un commissariat et c'est moi parler
quand vous rentrez dans un commissariat
jeunes vous êtes obligés de suivre le
mouvement et moi pour défendre des
policiers aux civils j'en ai les
témoignages donc arrêter avec ce
discours ultra corporatiste qui
cherchent à tous vous couvrir dénoncer
les violences et ensuite vous aurez un
succès odile et vous très respectable on
vous écoute accès le monde on vous
écoute sergent oui c'est vrai que c'est
pas ça nous avons aussi le droit à la
présomption d'innocence
nous sommes des citoyens effectivement
comme les autres il va pas falloir qu'un
emballement médiatique condamne tout de
suite nos collègues
encore une fois il ya huit mille
interventions chaque jour qui se passe
correctement malgré les tensions dans
notre pays
je vous rappelle que la délinquance a
explosé depuis la fée locaux vides
depuis les confinements les
déconfinement il y a énormément de
criminalité est en train d'exploser mesf
collection débordé par cette violence
chaque jour sur le territoire national
de plus en plus de fonctionnaires de
police ont blessé on ne peut pas laisser
ça qu'à la police nationale il y a aussi
un problème de justice dans notre pays
il faut le dire la non application de
certaines peines créé des crispations au
sein de notre corporation bien
évidemment maintenant il ya une faute
qu'il le reconnaisse la violence était
disproportionnée il faut ils vont
répondre
1 il va y avoir quand je vous dis une
enquête et après ils ont répondront
devant un juge
mais ça va prendre un petit peu de temps
on ne peut pas mettre des fonctionnaires
de police dans en détention provisoire
j'espère que ça ne va pas avoir lieu
on verra exactement ce qui se passera
mais en tout cas ce sera un très mauvais
message envoyé aux forces de l'ordre qui
sont je vous dis régulièrement pris pour
cible sur le thé
on ne nie pas effectivement là la
difficulté d'exercer ce ce travail de
policier néanmoins antonin peschard on a
l'impression ce soir que les policiers
ont été en comparu comme des individus
lambda effectivement vous pensez que on
va pouvoir
réformer si je puis dire le ski se passe
de façon est extrêmement rare dans au
sein de la police mais j'ai envie de
vous répondre en prenant le contre-pied
de votre question la difficulté
difficultés de l'enquêté deux juges et
des policiers
elle doit pas s'entendre sur le plan ii
du rapport qui va s'établir du coup
entre le parquet la magistrature et les
policiers derrière monsieur ronde en a
fait son argument en disant c'est un
mauvais message envoyé à la police
non le message que le gouvernement doit
envoyer c'est d'abord à ses citoyens
c'est pas à sa police la police elle est
au service de l'état et ce n'est pas le
contraire
donc les policiers ne doivent pas être
jugés de la même manière stricto sensu
que un citoyen entre guillemets que vous
appelez lambda mais justement ils
doivent être jugés encore plus
sévèrement parce que vous avez un code
de déontologie monsieur je vous le
rappelle parce que à force de lire des
gains âgées on se rend compte vous finir
on se rend compte qu'il n'est pas
appliquée pas appliquée du tout et ce
code de déontologie vous soumet à
l'exemplarité donc l'exemplarité ça veut
dire une justice plus sévère
j'ouvre mail que nous sommes la
profession la plus sanctionnée de la
fonction publique un suffit de regarder
un les décisions qu'il y a au niveau de
administrative nous sommes surveillés
ultra surveillé et là nous réclamons
même encore une surveillance
supplémentaire puisque nous demandent
donc des caméras portatives sur noah qui
fonctionne c'est ça que nous l'urgence
pour nous mais c'est quand même un petit
peu grave c'est que maintenant la parole
du policier est mis en doute en
permanence je rappelle que toutes les 30
minutes il ya un refus d'obtempérer en
france 1 dans notre pays
ça veut dire que l'on met en danger les
policiers mais on met en danger les
citoyens pour simplement un feu grillé
ça prend des proportions inimaginables
nos collègues sont je vous dis ce
travail dans l'urgence en permanence
l'urgence est notre quotidien et ne sais
il n'y a plus
moyen d'avoir du recul avec cette
violence qui a dans notre société c'est
la société eut malheureusement qe2 qui
est de plus en plus violentes et nous
sommes forcément pris là dedans c'est
pas nous qui voulons ce forcément cette
violence on l'a bien vu hier sur la
manifestation
on s'est payé du du policier excusez moi
mais on ya eu à peu près 80 18
fonctionnaires de police et de gendarmes
qui ont été blessés certains ont été
lynchées des dents cassées est-ce que ça
c'est normal et ce qu'on entend des
personnalités condamnées comme on a pu
condamner ce qui a été ce qui a été fait
par ses farces et policiers donc il faut
vraiment nous mettre aussi j'ai envie de
dire on est dans la société
on nous exclut dont nous excluant quand
il ya des violences contre nous il faut
aussi en parler lui dénoncé automne en
pêcheur effectivement il ya eu beaucoup
de policiers blessés hier lors des
manifestations à cause d'une affaire qui
n'a rien à voir avec ces crs et c'est un
gendarme qui étaient dans la rue hier
donc où est ce qu'il faudrait placer le
curseur de façon à ne pas généraliser
effectivement une tragédie comment est
ce que vous voyez les choses
cette manifestation c'est le l'événement
dont on parle a été le déclencheur de
cette manifestation qui a tourné autour
d'un projet de loi est extrêmement
symbolique ou est-ce qu'il faut placer
le curseur s'est lassé la très juste
question que vous nous posez écouter le
discours de monsieur ronde et je le
regrette parce que je sens que c'est de
très bonnes intentions mais dans votre
discours monsieur fou perpétuer cette
opposition entre la police et le citoyen
alors est-ce que c'est des citoyens qui
exclut la police
est ce que c'est la police qui ne peut
pas recevoir la confiance des citoyens
il faut arrêter de se demander à qui la
faute et travailler sur rétablir un
dialogue de confiance quand vous dites
monsieur et j'en suis très heureux et le
premier avis qui vous faut des caméras
portatives
oui mais aujourd'hui vous réclamez ça
est-ce que vos collègues portent le
numéro et rio qui sont censés porter
tous les jours en service
non monsieur je réponds à votre place
mais non c'est faux de dire que vous
portez votre numéro et rio donc il
faudrait déjà commencer par là accès
axelrod le est rude et il portait et et
que dire de la confiance réclamées par
emmanuel macron il a demandé à son
gouvernement de réfléchir à des
propositions pour pouvoir rétablir la
confiance entre les citoyens et la
police le et rio est porté par les
fonctionnaires de police de toute façon
quand il ya un souci on retrouve les
fonctionnaires de police on sait
exactement où ils sont positionnés
surtout en matière de l'ordre on les
retrouve assez facilement
il ya aucun problème par rapport à cela
les policiers sont identifiables
maintenant la confiance qui lie à anvers
la police s'est dégradée baisse depuis
de nombreuses années un monsieur darmana
essaye de recoller un peu les morceaux
c'est vrai il est en train de nous
donner plus de moyens en train de
d'essayer de de plus de communication
maintenant on part de très loin
je le problème comme je vous dis c'est
la justice nous sommes aussi arriver au
bout de nos limites à quand vous arrêtez
des petits gamins de 10 12 ans tous les
jours et qui vous tiennent tête qu'est
ce que vous voulez faire c'est un
problème j'ai envie de dire globalement
au niveau de l'éducation au niveau de la
société
ce n'est pas un problème police citoyens
c'est un problème plus général au niveau
de la france aucune manifestation dans
le pays aujourd'hui ne se passe bien
aucune ça finit toujours très mal
pourquoi il ya quand même un problème on
peut pas accuser en permanence la police
d'attiser les haines
comment ça se fait que maintenant des
contrôles de police se passe très mal en
permanence tous les jours pourquoi
monsieur d'abonnés si vous permettez je
vais rebondir sur ce que vous dites si
vous permettez je donne des gens
saignent à sciences po ce qu'on peut
considérer comme la future élite
politique du pays le premier sujet qui
est venu en classe cette semaine ce sont
ces violences policières et on a passé
la moitié du cours sur la question c'est
à dire que même la future élite
politique n'a pas confiance dans la
police c'est pas du tout un sujet global
monsieur oui il ya un problème
d'éducation
la justice est sous doté de moyens tout
comme la police et ça il faut le
reconnaître quand on voit l'état des
commissariats
je comprends qu'on ait du mal à aimer
son travail quand on va travailler dans
ces conditions ça c'est un vrai souci ça
on peut en discuter mais ne votez pas en
touche en disant que c'est un sujet
global alors que le problème c'est le
problème de la police quelle a été la
première croisilles proposition de mes
étudiants rétablir la police de
proximité qui avait fait ses preuves et
vous laisse dans le dans le tour
coercitif aujourd'hui il ya une vieille
olivier une police de proximité qui est
mis en place
bien évidemment nous allons au contact
de plus en plus mais nous travaillons
dans l'urgence en permanence le problème
c'est que les interventions de police
explose dans notre pays
nous sommes comme je vous dis dans
certaines zones des bordes et nous avons
certaines zones en france n'avaient pas
l'habitude d'avoir des violences
urbaines ça ça déborde de partout
il ya eu une attaque dans un
commissariat à cahors le il ya quelques
jours donc on se retrouve forcément avec
des fonctionnaires de police qui sont un
petit peu désarmée parce que non plus là
ils n'ont pas l'habitude de cancon les
attaques à ça restait très cloisonné
dans certaines métropoles sur l'île de
france dans certains endroits mais
maintenant ça se généralise sur tout le
territoire national
et ça c'est très très inquiétant de
propos c'est que la police n'a pas
réussi à faire son travail pendant
toutes ces années ci la justice
l'adjectif mais ça me dit qu'il ya une
chance aussi de méthodes qu'il faut
changer on va pas refaire le débat sur
la police et la justice on sait que
c'est compliqué on sait que les deux les
deux manques manque de moyens on en a
beaucoup parlé sur ce plateau antonin
pécha dernière question simplement est
ce que vous ne pensez pas que c'est
cette affaire est clair va devenir une
affaire politique mais je l'espère
madame je l'espère sincèrement parce que
c'est la première fois où on a des cimes
âge qui sont incontestables qui sont
reconnus et qui démontre que tout ce
qu'on dénonce depuis des années on passe
pour des hurluberlus à dire bon client a
été violentée en garde à vue mon client
a été violentée et cetera et cetera en
apportant les preuves qu'on peut parce
que vous savez que les procès verbaux
font foi et que nous on se retrouve
démuni qu'on n'a pas accès au dossier et
ben j'espère que ça va être politique
madame parce que ça permettra de
retraite de re place
le curseur du débat avec une information
avec laquelle tout le monde serait
éclairée pour apprendre un avis un avis
légitime
axelrod vraiment on a très peu de temps
affaires politiques détention provisoire
si elle est prononcée ce soir quelle
serait votre réaction
on serait totalement déçu quand je vous
dis c'est serait un très mauvais très
mauvais signal alors que actuellement
c'est très très compliqué dans plusieurs
zones en france
maintenant on espère que ce ne soit pas
une récupération politique
nous sommes des hommes des sommes des
êtres humains et nous avons
malheureusement d'aider des failles et
oui nous pouvons commettre des erreurs
chaque profession comme et aussi de
temps à autre des erreurs donc faut pas
généraliser 99 99% des cas ça se passe
bien
nos interventions voilà nous sommes
garants de la loi garant de la
république nous sommes nous sommes
animés par la protection de nos citoyens
de nos concitoyens nous sommes dans la
france nous sommes nous faisons partie
du tissu social ne sommes pas des
ennemis comme certains essayent à
certains de nos détracteurs
on l'a vu hier ils étaient là pour se
payer du pauliste y est pour que le
chaos règne
c'est finalement ce qui les anime il
faut faire attention et rester très
équilibré sur la décision politique
précis merci beaucoup à tous les deux
d'avoir un débattu de cette question ce
soir en direct sur rt français